>>> YOU JUST TAPPED INTO THE
"GROUP CHAT LIVE" PRESENTED BY
FAN DUEL.
I'M GREG IVORY ALONGSIDE THE
MAN, THE MYTH, THE LEGEND, SAM
RICHMOND.
THIS WEEKEND IS ALL-STAR WEEKEND
SO WE GOT A LOT TO TALK ABOUT,
SAM AND ALSO, SAM, WE'RE GIVING
AWAY AN iPHONE 13 RIGHT HERE ON
THIS SHOW.
SAM, THIS IS YOUR SECOND TIME.
YOU'RE NO LONGER A ROOKIE.
DID YOU BRING THE LOCKS FOR US
TODAY?
>> ALWAYS GREG.
YOU HYPE ME SO UP SO MUCH, I
COULD NEVER LET YOU DOWN SO YES,
WE ARE GOING TO WIN.
WE'RE GOING TO WIN BIG TODAY.
I LOVE IT.
>> WE ARE GOING TO WIN AND BIN
BIG.
SAM IS SENDING US AND GIVING US
THE GOOD VIBES THE JUJU.
WE'RE GIVING AWHICH A LOT OF
iPHONE 13.
I HAVE YET TO GET AN iPHONE 13.
DO YOU BY ANY CHANCE HAVE ONE
ALREADY?
>> NO, I DON'T.
I'M GLAD YOU BROUGHT THAT UP,
DEPRE
GREG.
I WAS GOING TO FLAG THAT.
ARE CO-HOSTS ELIGIBLE?
IF NOT I'D LIKE TO HAVE A LONG
CONVERSATION WITH OUR PRODUCER.
I'M GELLIOUS OF TH IOU
GE.
>> WE'RE GIVING AWAY LOCKS,
HOODIES AND JERSEYS AND WE ARE
GIVING AWAY THAT iPHONE 13 SO I
NEED GIFS AND COMMENTS IN THE
OWE ME
EMOJIS AND WINNERS ONLY PLEASE.
I'M ABOUT TO GIVE AWAY A JERSEY
RIGHT NOW, I SEE SNOOPY
21532GABASUNSETSAM.
SNOOPY, YOU ARE WALKING AWAY
WITH A JERSEY OF YOUR CHOICE,
SUNSET IS THE WAY TO MY HEART.
SAM, IT'S TNT BASKETBALL
THURSDAY.
WHICH MEANS WE ARE BETTING THE
3x2.
WILL THERE BE TWO THREE-POINTERS
IN THE FIRST THREE MINUTES OF
THE BECAME?
THERE'S ONLY ONE GAME TONIGHT,
SAM, ON TNT, SO WE ASKED YOU ON
TWITTER, ARE YOU RIDING THE
BUCKS/SIXERS 3x2?
IT IS BOOSTED FROM MINUS 110 TO
PLUS 120, DO YOU LIKE THOSE
ODDS?
>> I MEAN, IT'S WHAT'S THERE TO
SAY, A BOOSTED 3x2.
OF COURSE I LIKE IT.
I'LL GO A STEP FURTHER AND
PREDICT NOT ONLY IT HITS BUT WHO
CASHES IT FOR US.
DANNY GREEN THREE, I'LL GO KHRIS
MIDDLETOWN THREE AND THAT'S HOW
WE CATCH THIS TONIGHT.
LET'S GO.
>> THAT IS HOW WE'RE CASHING
THIS IN.
I SAW WHAT YOU DID.
YOU ARE MANIFESTING, MENTIONING
NAMES THAT YOU THINK THAT ARE
GOING TO CASH THIS 3x2.
I SEE THE GOOD VIBE.
I SEE THE JUJU AND I LIKE WHAT
YOU ARE DOING THERE.
LET ME HOP INTO THE COMMENTS,
I'M GIVING AWAY HOODIES AND ALSO
WE ARE GIVING AWAY THAT iPHONE
13 AND MAYBE, MAYBE I MIGHT GIVE
IT AWAY HERE, BUT I DO NOT KNOW.
I GOT JONES JORDAN, ROCKING WITH
US, HE SAYS YES, HE'S ROCKING
WITH US IN THE 3x2, SHOUT OUT TO
YOU, WALKING AWAY WITH A HOODIE.
ALSO, OHENRY SAYS THE 3x2 SOUNDS
LEGIT.
YOU ARE ALSO WALKING AWAY WITH A
HOODIE.
T.J., T.J. IS SPAMMING US IN THE
COMMENTS.
BROTHER, I'M HERE TO TELL YOU
THAT IS NOT HOW YOU GET A HOODIE
BY SPAMMING THE COMMENTS.
GIVE US GOOD TAKES.
THAT IS HOW YOU GUYS ARE WALKING
AWAY WITH GOOD, THAT'S HOW YOU
WALK AWAY WITH HADIS.
WE ARE RIDING THE MILWAUKEE
BUCKS VERSUS THE 76ers 3x2
TONIGHT.
LET'S GET RICH SAM AND TALK
MAJOR MARKETS, MONEY LINES
AGAINST THE SPREAD AND POINT
TOTALS FOR TONIGHT'S GAME.
LOOK AT THE ODDS, SAM, WHAT ARE
YOU SEEING HERE AND WHAT DO YOU
LIKE?
>
>> I LIKE THIS GAME, TOOK THE
76ers PLUS 6 1/2.
PEOPLE COULD ARGUE IT'S PHILLY
ROAD GAME, LAST GAME BEFORE THE
ALL-STAR BREAK, HARDEN COMING
BACK, MAYBE THEY'LL LOOK AHEAD
AND MAIL IT IN.
I REALLY LIKE THIS AS A
SITUATIONAL SPOT FOR PHILLY.
THEY JUST GOT BLOWN OUT ON
TUESDAY BY THE CELTICS ON
NATIONAL TV, I THINK THAT MEANS
SOMETHING, THE FACT THIS GAME IS
BACK ON TNT, NATIONAL TV, GOOD
OPPORTUNITY FOR THEM TO KIND OF
REDEEM THEMSELVES.
I THINK ALSO A SPOTTY L I LIKE,
MAYBE THE LAST GAMES FOR EMBIID
BEFORE HARDEN COMES ALONG.
SOMEONE MAKING AN MVP PUSH, HE'S
GOING TO CARE ABOUT THAT AND
WANT TO SHOW OUT.
I CAN SEE HIM GOING FOR 35, 40
MAYBE.
AND ALSO, YOU JUST LOOK AT THE
BUCKS ARE MISSING ABOUT FIVE TO
SIX GUYS IN THE ROTATION.
I THINK THE FOCUS IS PROBABLY
GOING TO BE ON PHILLY DOESN'T
HAVE HARDEN, BUT PHILLY HAS MOST
OF THEIR DUDES.
THE BUCKS DON'T.
I THINK THAT CATCHES UP WITH
THEM THERE.
YOU GET 6 1/2 POINTS WITH A
REALLY GOOD SIXERS TEAM.
I'M ALL OVER IT.
>> I'M RIGHT THERE WITH YOU.
LAST TIME WE SAW THE 76ers THEY
LAID AN EGG AGAINST THE BOSTON
CELTICS ON NATIONAL TELEVISION.
I DO NOT SEE THAT HAPPENING
AGAIN TO A DOC RIVERS TEAM.
I SEE THEM GOING INTO MILWAUKEE
AND PLAYING A COMPETITIVE GAME,
AND YOU MENTIONED THAT BUCKS
TEAM ARE KIND OF BEAT UP.
SOME GUYS ARE OUT, PHILADELPHIA
76ers TEAM DON'T HAVE JAMES
HARDEN BUT THEY STILL HAVE THEIR
TEAM, THEY STILL HAVE THAT DEPTH
SO I SEE THEM BOUNCING BACK.
GIVE ME SIXERS PLUS THE POINTS.
IN THE COMMENTS, THOUGH, I WANT
TO KNOW WHAT THEY ARE TALKING
ABOUT.
UH-OH, SAM, WE GOT JAKE ELSTON,
SAYS THE SIXER, GOING TO LOSE.
SAM, WHAT WE DO HERE ON OUR
SHOW, WE SHOW BAD VIBES/GOOD
VIBES.
MY GUY IS BASICALLY FADING US.
JAKE, YOU ARE WALKING AWAY WITH
A HOODIE.
I HOPE THAT TREATS YOU WELL AND
I HOPE THEY GET A W.
WE'LL BE CASHING OUR BETS.
BACK INTO THE COMMENTS, THOUGH,
SAM, I SEE BRAIDY P13, I LIKE
THAT, YOU ARE ALSO WALKING AWAY
WITH A HOODIE.
MAKE SURE YOU GUYS STICK AROUND,
BECAUSE WE'RE GOING TO TALK
ABOUT SOME ALL-STAR BETS AND
WE'RE GIVING OUT THAT iPHONE 13,
BUT BEFORE WE DO THAT, WE HAVE
TO BUILD THE BR BETTING SAME
GAME PARLAY.
TONIGHT WE'RE LOOKING AT THIS
BUCKS/SIXERS GAME AND I NEED
EVERYBODY AND I MEAN EVERYBODY
TO GET IN THE COMMENTS AND TELL
ME WHAT THEY ARE THINKING, WHICH
LEGS ARE LOCKED, WHICH LEGS ARE
NOT.
SAM, LET'S GET RIGHT TO IT.
WE WERE JUST TALKING ABOUT THIS,
MAN, JOEL EMBIID HAS ABSOLUTELY
BEEN ON A TEAR SINCE JANUARY.
SINCE THE BEGINNING OF JANUARY
ON A TEAR, HIS NUMBERS HAVE BEEN
CRAZY.
I NEED HIM TO GET 30 TONIGHT,
SAM.
I MEAN, THIS SEEMS LIKE A
LAY-UP.
YOU LOOK AT JOEL EMBIID'S
NUMBERS SINCE THE BEGINNING OF
JANUARY, 30 POINTS SEEMS LIKE A
LAY-UP.
DO YOU LIKE THIS ONE OR DO YOU
NOT?
>> YES, LIKE I SAID WITH THE
GAME PICK, I LIKE THIS SPOT FOR
EMBIID.
I THINK HE CARES ABOUT MVP AND
REALIZES THIS IS ONE OF THE LAST
TIMES ON A NATIONALLY TELEVISED
GAME I'LL BE THE SEASONAL
SUPERSTAR ON THE TEAM, I THINK
HE GOES FOR 30, 35, MAYBE MORE.
>> SAM IS ROCKIN' WITH THE JOEL
EMBIID PICK, STARTING OFF WELL.
LET'S MOVE ON TO GIANNIS
ANTETOKOUNMPO.
WE'RE NOT TALKING POINTS.
WE'RE NOT TALKING ASSISTS.
BUT WE ARE TALKING REBOUNDS
HERE, SAM.
CAN GIANNIS GO UP THERE AND GRAB
10 REBOUNDS TONIGHT?
>> YES, I THINK SO.
HE'S AVERAGING CLOSE TO 12 THIS
MONTH, AGAIN, THE BUCKS ARE
LACKING SOME DEPTH, AND SOME BIG
MEN IN THERE, TOO, SO IT
REQUIRES GIANNIS TO DO A LITTLE
BIT MORE OF THE DIRTY WORK.
I THINK HE GETS THERE.
I DON'T THINK IT WILL BE MUCH OF
A PROBLEM.
>> OKAY, OKAY, OKAY.
I LIKE THE FIRST TWO PICKS, BUT
THIS PICK RIGHT HERE, IT JUST, I
DON'T KNOW.
I JUST DON'T KNOW ABOUT IT, BUT
SAM, HOPEFULLY YOU CAN TALK ME
OUT THE WAY I'M FEELING.
WE GOT KHRIS MIDDLETOWN TO MAKE
TWO THREE-POINTERS, ONLY TWO,
SAM, ONLY TWO.
DO YOU THINK MY GUY CHRKHRIS
MIDDLETOWN CAN KNOCK DOWN TWO
THREE-POINTERS TONIGHT?
>> SO I WAS FEELING, I FEEL GOOD
ABOUT THIS.
I WAS FEELING BETTER BEFORE THAT
COMMENT YOU TALKED ABOUT LOCKING
OUT MIDDLETOWN, GOOD VIBES FOR A
SIXERS BET BUT BAD VIBES FOR
THIS.
I THINK MIDDLETOWN STRUGGLED
FROM THE THREE-POINT LINE
RECENTLY.
THE THING I LIKE EVEN IF HE'S
NOT MAKING THE SHOTS HE'S
GETTING THEM UP.
YOU LOOK AT THE LAST FEW GAMES,
1 FOR 8, 1 FOR 6.
AS LONG AS HE'S SHOOTING SEVEN
OR EIGHT THREES I THINK HE'S
GOING TO HIT TWO.
HE'S A LOT BETTER THAN WHAT IS
IT, 25% FREE-THROW SHOOTER,
SORRY, THREE-POINT SHOOTER.
IF HE TAKES SEVEN OR EIGHT OF
THESE I THINK HE'S GETTING TWO
IN.
>> MY MAN SAM IS OVER THERE
CRUNCHING DOWN THE NUMBERS.
WE'RE LIVE AND HE'S CRUNCHING
DOWN THE NUMBERS AS HE SPEAKS.
MIDDLETOWN TO GO OVER TWO
THREE-POINTERS, WE'RE SENDING
THE GOOD VIBES FOR THAT.
LET'S MOVE ON TO HIS POINT
GUARD, HIS POINT GUARD AND WE'RE
NOT TALKING ASSISTS.
WE'RE TALKING POINTS HERE WITH
JRUE HOLIDAY TO GO OVER 15
POINTS, SAM, TALK TO ME.
TALK TO ME NICE.
DO YOU LIKE THIS LEG OF THE
PARLAY?
>> YES, HE'S AVERAGING 19 POINTS
THIS MONTH.
HE'S HAD A FEW GAMES, ONE OF
THOSE IN THE 23 RANGE.
HE'S GOTTEN TO 20 A HANDFUL OF
GAMES U TIMES.
I THINK HOLIDAY HITS, I THINK
GIANNIS AND EMBIID HIT.
IT'S MIDDLETOWN, IF WE CAN GET
THAT SECOND THREE THAT'S THE
DIFFERENCE BUT I THINK HOLIDAY
GETS IT DONE.
>> YOU MENTIONED AS LONG AS HE'S
PUTTING UP THOSE SHOTS, MAN, WE
REALLY CAN'T BE MAD AT THAT.
AS LONG AS THE SHOTS IS GETTING
PUT UP, HEY, WE'RE TAKING OUR
CHANCES ON THIS BET, SO WE'LL
SEE, BUT WHAT I WANT TO SEE
RIGHT NOW, SAM, IS IF WE WERE TO
PUT $100 DOWN, HOW MUCH MONEY
WILL WE BE WALKING AWAY WITH?
LET'S PULL UP THE TICKET SO WE
CAN SHOW YOU THAT RIGHT NOW.
IF YOU GUYS WERE TO PUT $100
DOWN, YOU'RE WALKING AWAY WITH
$427.08.
GO PUT THIS IN, GO GET RICH,
HEY, SAM, BUT BEFORE I GET INTO
THE COMMENTS, WERE YOU GRADING
THE SAME GAME PARLAY?
>> I LOVE WHEN YOU ASK ME TO
GRADE THE PARLAY I HELPED BUILD.
OBVIOUSLY I'LL GIVE IT AN "A."
LIKE I SAID, I'M ALWAYS GOING TO
GIVEN A PARLAY I BUILT AN "A."
I'M MORE CURIOUS WHAT YOU GRADE
THIS AT.
>> SAM, I LOVE YOUR PARLAY,
BROTHER.
YOU KNOW I THINK YOU'RE SHARP,
ONE OF THE BEST BETTERS ON THE
BR BETTING STAFF.
I LOVE YOUR PARLAY, BUT THERE'S
JUST BEEN THIS THING AND I DON'T
KNOW WHAT IT IS, WILL YOU LIV
GIVES US B MINUSES AND WE HIT,
EVERY TIME SHE GIVES US A B
MINUS WE USUALLY HIT SO I'LL
CONTINUE THOSE TRENDS, CONTINUE
THAT JUJU.
MY HEART WANTS TO GIVE IT AN AS
"A" BUT MY MIND GIVES IT A B
MINUS BECAUSE I WANT TO SEE IT
GO THROUGH THE NET.
I'M GIVING IT A B MINUS, ROCKING
WITH YOU.
LET ME GET TO THE COMMENTS, SAM.
I GOT TO SEE WHAT THEY ARE
TALKING ABOUT AND I'M GIVING
AWAY HOODIES, I'M ALSO GIVING
AWAY A JERSEY.
I GOT SANFRAN SAYS THE SIXERS
ARE GOING TO BOUNCE BACK FROM
THE CELTICS L, GAVE US A JOEL
EMBIID GIFT, SAN FRAN CITY A
HOODIE OF YOUR CHOICE, I LOVE
THAT TAKE AND ENDERMAN IS IN THE
CONFERENCE, ALWAYS GIVES US GOOD
TAKES.
EMBIID GOING TO GET OVER 30
POINTS.
JIAN SIGIANNIS IS GOING TO GET
TEN-PLUS REBOUNDS AND MIDDLETOWN
20 PLUS JOINTS, JRUE 15 POINTS.
YOU'RE WALK AWAY WITH A HOODIE.
I HAVE TO GIVE AWAY THIS JERSEY,
SAM.
I GOT TO GIVE THIS JERSEY AWAY
AND I SEE JACK COSTA.
JACK COSTA, HE GAVE US AN A
MINUS BECAUSE OF THE GOOD VIBES,
JACK, YOU ARE WALKING AWAY WITH
A JERSEY OF YOUR CHOICE.
TIME TO TALK THE ALL-STAR GAME,
SUNDAY AT 8:00 ON TNT.
THE THREE-POINT CONTEST IS
SATURDAY NIGHT AND I CANNOT
WAIT.
LET'S TAKE A LOOK AT THE ODDS.
SAM, WHAT DO YOU LIKE?
ACTUALLY, NOT WHAT, BUT WHO DO
YOU LIKE TO WIN THE THREE-POINT
CONTEST THIS YEAR?
>> THIS SAN INTERESTING
THREE-POINT CONTEST MORE THAN
PAST YEARS, THE KLAYS OF THE
WORLD, YOU WERE ALWAYS PLUS 125,
PLUS 200.
THIS IS A COMPLETELY WIDE OPEN
FIELD.
THIS IS KIND OF A CRAP SHOOT.
I'M LIKING A LUKE CUNARD PLUS
600.
HE HAS THE BEST THREE-POINT
PERCENTAGE OF ANYONE IN THIS
FIELD SO AT PLUS 600, I'LL TAKE
MY CHANCE WITH CUNARD.
WHY NOT?
>> I LIKE THAT PICK, SAM.
LUKE CUNARD HAS THE BURNER.
HE HAS THE FIRE BLOWING FROM THE
LEFT AND HE'S A LEFTY.
I LIKE THAT.
I'M WITH YOU STICKING TOWARDS
THE BOTTOM OF THE LIST, BUT I
WANT TO GO TO THE VERY, I HAVE
BOTTOM, THAT IS CARL ANTHONY
TOWNES.
HE IS ONE ONE OF THE BIG MAN
SHOOTING CENTERS IN HISTORY.
I THINK HE'LL GO OUT TO
CLEVELAND AND PUT ON A SHOW.
IT'S PLUS 1200 ON THE COIN FLIP.
GIVE ME MY MAN TO GO WIN THIS
ONE.
I'M IN THE COMMENTS.
I'M IN THE COMMENTS, GIVING AWAY
HOODIES BECAUSE I WANT TO SEE
WHO THEY ARE ROCKING WITH.
OHENRY69 SAYS CUNARZ FIRE.
SHOUT OUT TO YOU, WALKING AWAY
WITH A HOODIE.
I SEE RELO SAYS TREY I DIDN'T
THINK FOR ME, C.J. IS ALSO A
DARK HORSE.
SHOUT OUT TO YOU, RELO, YOU ARE
WALKING AWAY WITH A HOODIE.
I'LL LEAVE THE COMMENTS ALONE,
BECAUSE WE'RE ABOUT TO TALK SLAM
DUNK CONTEST NOW.
LET'S TAKE A LOOK AT THE CURRENT
ODDS.
SAM, WHO DO YOU LIKE TO WIN THE
SLAM DUNK CONTEST, BROTHER?
>> THIS IS A TOUGH FIELD.
EVERYONE FEELS SO CLOSE.
I'LL TAKE COLE ANTHONY PLUS 250.
I THINK NICE HYPE AROUND HIM,
HE'S BEEN A FUN PLAYER THE LAST
TWO YEARS.
GUARDS USUALLY WIN THIS, SMALLER
GUARDS, SO HE FITS THE MOLD.
HE SEEMS LIKE A BIG GAME PLAYER
AND WILL WANT A SHOT.
I'M TAKING COLE ANTHONY.
I'M MORE CURIOUS OF YOUR PICK.
IF YOUR HISTORY REPEATS ITSELF
YOU TAKE J.T.A. FROM THE
WARRIORS.
AM I RIGHT THERE, ARE YOU TAKING
ANDERSON?
>> I'M ONLY GOING TO SPRINKLE
J.T.A. SIMPLY BECAUSE HE HAS THE
DRAYMOND ENDORSEMENT.
I FIRMLY BELIEVE DRAYMOND'S NOT
JUST GOING TO ENDORSE ANYBODY.
I KNOW DRAYMOND, THE TYPE OF GUY
HE IS.
HE'S NOT GOING TO GO OUT THERE
AND SAY ANYTHING ABOUT ANYBODY
THAT HE DOESN'T BELIEVE THEY
COULD GO OUT THERE AND DO
SOMETHING, SO HE SAID J.T.A. CAN
GO OUT THERE AND WIN.
I'LL SPRINKLE SOMETHING ON
J.T.A. BUT I'M HERE TO TELL THE
PEOPLE THAT ARE WATCHING WHAT I
SAW WITH MY OWN TWO EYES LAST
YEAR, AT THE SUMMER LEAGUE, SAM,
AND THAT WAS O.B. TOPPIN, GOING
ABSOLUTELY BANANAS IN PREGAME
WARMUPS DUNKING THE BALL.
HE WAS 360s, DOING IT ALL IN
WARMUPS BEFORE HE PLAYED A GAME,
SO SAM.
HE'S NOT GOING TO PLAY A GAME
SATURDAY NIGHT.
HE'S GOING TO HAVE DECENT FRESH
LEGS.
PLUS 200, I WANT TO ROCK THAT
WAY, SAM.
I'M IN THE COMMENTS.
LET ME HOP IN THE COMMENTS.
JALEN GREEN ONE OF MY FAVORITE
PLAYER, SHOUT OUT TO YOU.
YOU ARE WALKING AWAY WITH A
HOODIE.
I SEE L. DAVIS, DeMAR WINNING
ALL-STAR MVP.
WHOA, WE'RE NOT THERE YET, L.
DAVIS, BUT SHOUT OUT TO YOU FOR
COMMENTING.
I SEE EZDEFEAT, DIE HARD KNICKS
FANS COMING OUT TO DOMINATE,
ROCKING WITH MY PIC, SHOUT OUT
TO YOU, WALKING AWAY WITH A
HOODIE.
SAM, LET'S MOVE ON, STILL
TALKING ALL-STAR GAME.
LET'S TALK MAJOR MARKETS FOR THE
ALL-STAR GAME.
LET'S TAKE A LOOK AT THE ODDS,
SAM, WHAT DO YOU LIKE, ARE YOU
TEAM K.D. OR TEAM LeBRON?
>> I MEAN, LOOK.
TEAM LeBRON ROSTER IS
SIGNIFICANTLY BETTER THAN THE
TEAM DURANT ROSTER.
IT'S REALLY NOT EVEN CLOSE.
THAT SAID I'M TAKING THE SIX
POINTS.
THIS IS AN EXHIBITION GAME WHERE
THE TALENT DIFFERENCE DOESN'T
MATTER.
ALL OF THE GUYS ARE REALLY,
REALLY GOOD I'LL TAKE THE SIX
POINTS.
THIS GAME IS MEANT TO BE FUN.
BLOWOUTS AREN'T FUN.
THE PLAYERS KNOW THAT AND I
THINK THE ALL-STAR GAME TWO
YEARS AGO, CAME DOWN TO THE
WIRE, WAS MORE EXCITING THAN THE
ONE LAST YEAR.
I THINK THE PLAYERS KNOW THAT.
I'LL TAKE THE SIX POINTS AND SEE
WHAT HAPPENS.
>> I'M ROCKING WITH THE OVER, AT
319 1/2 BUT GIVE IT TO ME.
I AM ROCKING.
USUALLY THEY DON'T PLAY DEFENSE
IN THE ALL-STAR GAMES.
NO ONE WANTS TO GET HURT.
A LOT OF BUCKETS AND THREE-POINT
SHOTS, PUT THE BALL IN THE
BASKETBALL.
I'M IN THE COMMENTS RIGHT NOW.
GIVING AWAY HOODIES.
I SEE GO GUARDEN IS IN THE
COMMENTS, BRON TEAM IS BETTER
BUT THINK K.D. AND COLE WILL BE
STOUT.
K.D. AND COMPANY WILL BE STOUT.
SHOUT OUT TO YOU, WALKING AWAY
WITH A HOODIE.
MKENT93 SAYS TEAM MINUS 6 ALL
DAY, ROCKIN' WITH TEAM LeBRON.
SHOUT OUT TO YOU, M.K., YOU'RE
ALSO WALKING AWAY WITH A HOODIE.
SAM, MY MAN LDAVIS MENTIONED
ALL-STAR MVP A COUPLE SEGMENTS
AGO BUT NOW WE'RE IN.
IT'S TIME TO GIVE AWAY THAT
iPHONE AS WELL, TODAY WE ASKED
YOU IN THE APP, WHO IS YOUR LOCK
TO WIN ALL-STAR MVP?
LET'S TAKE A LOOK AT THE CURRENT
NODS.
SAM, WHO DO YOU LIKE TO WIN
ALL-STAR MVP?
>> YES, THIS IS SO FUN.
THIS IS THE MOST FUN OF THE
WEEKEND.
THE GUY I'M TAKING IS GOING TO
BE FUN, TAKING JA MORANT PLUS
850.
THIS IS THE YEAR OF JA.
THIS IS A REALLY GOOD
OPPORTUNITY FOR HIS LIKE COMING
OUT PARTY AS AN OFFICIAL TOP
TIER NBA SUPERSTAR, THE BEST
HIGHLIGHTS OF ANYONE IN THE
LEAGUE RIGHT NOW.
YOU CAN'T GO TO BR HOUSE OF
HIGHLIGHTS AND NOT SEE HIM THERE
EVERY SINGLE NIGHT.
HE'S AN ABSOLUTE FREAK OF AN
ATHLETE.
HE'LL PROBABLY CARE ABOUT THIS
GAME MORE THAN SOME OF THE OLDER
VETS WHO HAVE BEEN THERE, DONE
THAT.
A HUGE JA MORANT SHOWCASE AND I
THINK HE FINISHES IT OFF WITH
ALL-STAR MVP AND TEAM K.D. SO
HE'S MY PICK AS WELL.
>> I LIKE THAT, SAM, I LIKE THAT
PICK A LOT.
JA MORANT GOT THE YOUNG LEGS.
HE GOT THOSE YOUNG LEGS IN THIS
ALL-STAR GAME.
HE MIGHT BE A LITTLE BIT SPRINGY
OUT THERE BUT I DO WANT TO TALK
ABOUT LeBRON JAMES GOING BACK TO
CLEVELAND.
LET'S JUST LET THAT SINK IN A
LITTLE BIT.
THIS MIGHT BE LeBRON JAMES' LAST
GAME IN CLEVELAND BEFORE THE
ALL-STAR GAME, MIGHT BE THE LAST
ALL-STAR GAME IN CLEVELAND IN
HIS CAREER AND MY MAN IS GOING
HOME.
I CAN SEE LeBRON JAMES PUTTING
UP NUMBERS.
IT'S HIS LAST TIME IN CLEVELAND
POTENTIALLY BEFORE THE
ALL-STARS.
HE'S PUTTING THE BALL IN THE
BUCKET ALL YEAR, AND WHY CAN'T
HE DO IT IN THE ALL-STAR GAME?
I'M ROCKING LeBRON TO WIN MVP
BUT I'M IN THE COMMENTS RIGHT
NOW, GIVING AWAY HOODIES BUT I'M
ALSO GIVING AWAY THAT iPHONE 13
AND IF I SEE A GOOD TAKE, SAM,
I'M JUST GOING TO GIVE AWAY THAT
iPHONE.
I SEE JOJO347, I'M TAKING LeBRON
JAMES, BACK TO CLEVELAND TAKING
THE WIN AND MVP, SHOUT OUT TO
YOU, JOJO, SENDING YOU A HOODIE
AND BUCKS WILL WIN.
GIANNIS WILL WIN AND I'LL BE
FINE IF HE WINS THE MVP, LET'S
GO GREEK FREAK, YOU'RE WALKING
AWAY WITH A HOODIE.
MONEY MUNCHER 10 SAYS GIANNIS
WAS COMPETITIVE LAST TIME AND
HIS TEAM IS GONNA WIN, MONEY
MUNCHER, YOU ARE WALKING AWAY
WITH THE iPHONE 13.
I LIKE YOUR TAKE.
YOU BROUGHT UP LAST YEAR, YOU
BROUGHT UP GIANNIS DOMINATING
LAST YEAR, HAVING A GOOD GAME.
YOU THINK HE'LL DO IT AGAIN AND
GET THE WIN, YOU ARE WALKING
AWAY WITH THAT iPHONE 13.
SAM, LET'S MOVE ON, BECAUSE WE
KNOW, I KNOW AND IF YOU GUYS
DON'T KNOW AT HOME, NOW YOU
KNOW, IF YOU WANT TO TALK
FUTURES, TALK FUTURES WITH MY
MAN, SAM.
SAM, YOU LOVE TALKING FUTURES
AND ALL-STAR BREAK IS A GOOD
TIME TO LOCK IN SOME FINAL
FUTURES.
LET'S TAKE A LOOK AT THE CURRENT
ODDS TO WIN IT ALL, SAM, ARE YOU
STILL HOLDING ONTO THAT JAZZ
FUTURE THAT YOU ONCE TALKED
ABOUT AND IF SO, OR IF NOT, WHAT
ELSE DO YOU LIKE NOW?
>> YES, NO, I MEAN, SHOUT OUT TO
FAN DUEL.
LAST TIME I WAS ON THE SHOW I
GAVE OUT THE JAZZ OF THE FUTURE
BUT THE GREAT THING ABOUT FAN
DUEL, YOU THE CASH OUT YOUR
BETS.
JAZZ WENT ON A LOSING STREAK AND
I STARTED BELIEVING IN THEM A
LITTLE BIT, I CASHED IT OUT AND
IF I SEE AN OPPORTUNITY TO
REINVEST IN THEM I CAN.
I MOVED ON FROM THE JAZZ AND DID
TAKE ANOTHER FUTURE.
I TOOK THE 76ers PLUS 1400, THE
HARDEN TRADE BEFORE THE LINE
MOVED.
I'M GOING TO KEEP RIDING WITH
THAT, 76ers PLUS 650.
I THINK HARDEN WAS MISERABLE IN
BROOKLYN.
I THINK HE'LL BE ENERGIZED IN
PHILLY AND BE AS WE TALKED
ABOUT, YOU SAID IT, JUST ON AN
ABSOLUTE FREAKING TEAR SINCE THE
START OF THE YEAR.
THAT AND THE PICK AND ROLL IS
LETHAL.
THEY DIDN'T LOSE A LOT OF DEPTH
IN THE TRADE SO I LIKE SIXERS
PLUS 650.
I THINK THIS IS THE YEAR FOR
HARDEN AND EMBIID TO GET IT
DONE.
>> I LIKE THAT, SAM.
I LIKE THAT A LOT.
I DO WANT TO TALK ABOUT
SOMETHING I'VE BEEN TALKING
ABOUT THE WHOLE YEAR SINCE THE
BEGINNING OF THE YEAR I'VE BEEN
ROCKING WITH THE GOLDEN STATE
WARRIORS TO WIN THE
CHAMPIONSHIP.
THE
THEY'RE ONE OF THE FAVORITES.
IT'S AT PLUS 460 NOW.
IF YOU WANT TO SPRINKLE IT, LOCK
THAT IN.
DO NOT BE ALARMED BY THE RECENT
TURMOIL AND STRUGGLES THEY'VE
BEEN GOING THROUGH.
I THINK THEY NEED TO HAVE FRESH
LEGS AND GET IGGY, DRAYMOND AND
WEISMAN BACK TO THE LINE-UP, AND
THE GOLDEN STATE WARRIORS WILL
BE JUST FINE AS FAR AS COMPETING
FOR A KMP.
I
CHAMPIONSHIP.
IF I WAS TO SPRINKLE SOMETHING
ELSE, GO IN ANOTHER DIRECTION,
THIS TRADE THAT JUST HAPPENED
LAST WEEK, BROOKLYN/76ers, I
WOULD SAY THE BROOKLYN NETS WON
THE TRADE, SAM.
THEY WON THE TRADE.
THEY GOT BEN SIMMONS.
THEY GOT MY GUY SETH CURRY.
I WOULD SAY OVERALL THEY WON THE
TRADE.
THE 76ers GOT JAMES HARDEN AND
JAMES HARDEN MIXED UP WITH JOEL
EMBIID RUNNING THE PICK AND ROLL
OFFENSE WITH DOC RIVERS AS THE
COACH?
OH, MY!
THAT IS A SCARY, SCARY SIGHT FOR
THE EAST, K.D. AND COMPANY, YOU
GUYS BETTER WATCH OUT.
GIANNIS AND COMPANY, YOU GUYS
BETTER WATCH OUT, PLUS 650, LAST
WEEK I SAID IT WAS PLUS 1100, IT
WENT DOWN TO PLUS 654, I'M RIGHT
THERE WITH YOU.
I LIKE THE 76ers.
IF I WAS TO GO AWAY FROM THE
WARRIORS I LIKE THE 76ers.
LET ME HOP INTO THE COMMENTS,
SAM.
LET ME HOP INTO THE COMMENTS.
I'M GIVING AWAY JERSEYS AND ALSO
GIVING AWAY HOODIES AND I SEE
JHEARNE123 SAYS GIANNIS HAS TO
BE THE FAVORITE TO WIN ALL-STAR
MVP.
HIS SOLID PLAY FITS PERFECTLY
WITH THE ALL-STAR GAME SO HE
WILL PUT UP A TON OF POINTS,
CATCHING LOBS, FAST BREAK
POINTS, EASY LAY-UPS AND POINTS
IN THE PAINT, HE'S ON LeBRON'S
TEAM AND THEY ALWAYS WIN AND
HAVE THE CLEAR ADVANTAGE THIS
YEAR.
SO GIANNIS IS THE GREAT ODDS TO
WIN ALL-STAR GAME MVP.
GIVE ME THE FREAK.
A.J., THAT WAS AN A-PLUS-PLUS
TAKE.
APPRECIATE YOU.
YOU ARE WALKING AWAY WITH A
JERSEY OF YOUR CHOICE AND A
HOODIE, JUST FOR THE TAKE.
LOVED IT.
I'M MOVING ON, IN THE BLUE IN
THE COMMENTS, NETS SCORE THE
TITLE, SHOUT OUT TO YOU.
KAY WALKER IN THE COMMENTS YES
TO THE BULLS WINNING THE
CHAMPIONSHIP AT PLUS 3,000.
SHOUT OUT TO YOU, K WALKER,
WALKING AWAY WITH A HOODIE.
SAM AND I GOT ONE MORE HOODIE,
MIKE BOWLEN TALKING ABOUT THE
BULLS.
G SAYS THE SIXERS GOING ALL THE
WAY AND THE SUNS WON'T STOP
EMBIID IN THE PAINT.
THERE IT IS.
YOU ARE WALKING AWAY WITH A
HOODIE, GQUINN BUT SAM, WE
REACHED THE END, BROTHER.
WE HAVE REACHED THE END.
I WANT TO THANK EVERYBODY THAT'S
HERE, IN THE COMMENTS, GIVING US
GOOD TAKES.
THANK YOU GUYS FOR TAPPING IN TO
THE "GROUP CHAT" PRESENTED BY
FAN DUEL.
REMEMBER WHAT YOU LEARNED TODAY.
WE ARE ALL RIDING THE
BUCKS/SIXERS 3x2 AS A FAMILY.
GET ON FAN DUEL AND TELL OUR BR
BETTING SAME GAME PARLAY, FOLLOW
US ALL WEEKEND LONG FOR ALL-STAR
LOCKS.
WE'LL BE BACK NEXT THURSDAY
GIVING OUT MORE HOODIES, MORE
LOCKS, MORE JERSEYS AND IF YOU
WANT A HOODIE TODAY, WE WILL DM
YOU, ALONGSIDE THE MAN, THE
MYTH, THE LEGEND, SAM RICHMOND.
I'M GREG IVORY.
WE ARE LEAVING THE "GROUP CHAT."
PEACE.
>> PEACE.
♪